look I know that I said that I would
tell you everything
but how much of everything do you really
want to know
[Music]
Riley Keough channels her Rockstar mom
Lisa Marie Presley and the upcoming
musical drama Daisy Jones and the six
I'm just a huge music fan music lover
it's really simple actually so I and I
knew that it's helped me through every
you know moment of my life it's gotten
me through things the late singer's
daughter plays 1970s fictitious lead
vocalist Daisy Jones of the band Daisy
Jones and the six in the Prime video
series which was adapted from Taylor
Jenkins reads best-selling novel of the
same name you write songs about who you
wish you were not who you are what if he
wrote songs about the guy that maybe
wants things that he shouldn't
I didn't want to hear a song about that
I think everybody would and Riley's
proving she's got some vocals on her the
trailer features the original song
regret me one of 24 written for the show
and recorded by the cast
[Music]
Riley seems to be diving into her
family's musical footsteps her Grandpa
of course being the king of rock and
roll Elvis Presley
[Music]
Falling in Love
way
I think I had a little record player and
just sitting in my room listening to it
all the time little 45
also my father recorded his one of his
final albums or his final album in this
room behind me so I remember being here
for that and all the carpet on the
ceilings and everything getting put up
so that he could record yeah and Riley's
late mother Lisa Marie was also inspired
by her dad as she went on to have a big
musical career herself
[Music]
it started off with me just myself
outleting and then because music's
always done that for me in spite of who
I am and where I've come from Riley has
since made a name for herself in the
acting world starring in films like The
Runaways Magic Mike and Mad Max Fury
Road
and there's the People Eater himself
coming to count the cost I've got so
many videos and little movies she's made
her whole life when she originated
that's what she wanted to do
and it was very
level-headed about it that I that I made
the decision but I didn't put her in the
Limelight before that she made that
determination for herself and then has
done really really well I couldn't be
more proud the actress even earned
herself a Golden Globe nomination for
her role in the girlfriend experience a
moment her loved ones were very proud
about too my family is kind of like do
you realize this is a huge deal I think
more than I do I don't know they're
they're kind of they're I think flipping
out more than more than I am and now
Riley's ready to shine in her latest
musical role Daisy Jones in the six
premieres March 3rd on Prime video
foreign
[Music]